event until caliber five was won by
Omega D arm which was Dominican Republic
and Lola mixes and when as follows right
now so Hofer game for the sigh me I feel
like wouldn't he want to repeat I feel
like you were going to repeat right come
on over here okay talk to me my boys
spicy out here man he got me he's on
block he catches you breathing he goes
uh uh not Today
he conditions him so well so early on
and this constant Stuttgart step card
separate the amount of clean is so
incredible but that's the thing to write
is that it comes to these sets and watch
them do the first of two sides at least
we would see that he would not really
utilize guards like a lot of guard break
attacks we would tend to be a lot more
channel this is like you know what get
it feel her out get a feel her out but
then when you start to actually
implement them it kind of picks up your
point
each chips is play cells just ever so
slightly which does create a massive
dynamic shift here we go we get to Game
one there'll be three out of five just
let you guys know snow more first two
twos anymore since iron winners finals
here let's get it rocking we have skill
versus a low low yeah so I mean you're
talking about the fact that this move of
three out of five and you're saying how
adaptations and using new things happen
we're three out of five is this is the
first one that we're seeing thus far so
we're gonna see some new stuff possibly
from both the players Lolo starting with
you dang he has three character Vale but
soon but you decided meaning with the
best exercise for sure and there we go
oats pacer for the six a but does not
matter oh gee I just like that getting
that damn it baby go rock it out then
set up the mix-up here pushing Lola
closer closer to the wall finally
getting the wall hit there's the second
one okay big damage on that there's a
mix-up he blocks the low this is here's
a chance to make him to come back but
knuckle gets the counter hit on that and
skill gonna take a first round
all right here we go into round 2 halo
will make something happen trim
something good you getting really choked
up right now you'll be super aggro yeah
hey man if you're not gonna learn when
to press I'm a press for you don't worry
no he's out oh no you were so close yeah
that's a prolonged outing you know the
thing is is like I you can actually just
make it to the third but the six meters
puts them out immediately if I remember
correctly don't worry about it you know
what he was like a celebration for
noodles of damage right now okay both
them have 1 meter to work with though
the GI Oh men that move does a 38% Guard
gauge damage dude it this yeah I mean
you know it also if you were to read you
either it's a bit slower so it might
have caught that but he's able to get me
low on the wall and yeah catching the
roll right there skills currently on
game point he's pushing low limits to
the brink okay a really great option
there okay stop them in the middle of it
I'm trying to put forward to getting the
sign throw right there as Lola make
she's gonna have a setup opportunity
bulb and I'm having to bar and yes
there's the dog on the floor he did not
want to deal with that busy time oh yeah
I didn't think on that one
that's like negative 20s also I
understand punishing right back with you
for sure Oh ended up going for the empty
jump low so he so what he did was the
empty jump where it's probably when you
do it regular jump most people are
expecting a low attack optimist right so
he then did a regular low afterwards
because he was like no no no you're
faking it and there's like no get away
from me
how about training it goes on pretty
promising damage-wise yeah I mean you
know earlier no the last game I believe
this person you talk about we saw just
melting that but lightbars wants us the
3d graphical card out Oh caught him it's
all very little help there's the lobster
right there what I am so surprised about
is when he talked that grant that he
didn't punish the CEO like he did while
writing a low-low just kind of walking
in it right you'd think that you know
what I don't wanna be a situation right
so trying to throw a launcher like that
and get punished and lose but he let the
risk happen and bang it worked for him
so I'll catch him good stuff yeah I feel
like Lolo has done such a strong job of
taking well be I would I can't see we
call a risk like that and just making a
mountain out of it
oh right there he's gonna be a big
update unfortunate just a little bit too
far away and that allows Lola to push
him out and it's kind of doing the same
exact thing right there eventually
taking it around
oh brain sleep wasn't there but not
today's a skill out facing it a little
more action here but nothing too crazy
oh my god just took a massive big boil
on chat not today yeah he wants to make
sure you get to whatever punchy can
whenever the just frame business right
there he's able to block the low as well
no lethal hit because I mean that wasn't
the tip range so it would've had he got
hit yeah I guess it was already safe he
got the step he's got the CD after the
watcher and I mean just wants to get
that lights a lot of guard damage right
now he was able to hit him out of the
air and the feed comes out drop a low
baby let's go home alive though Oh in
there yeah I mean it's big yeah that was
like just scraping on by a thread there
brother so I get it all right everybody
if that one got blocked it could have
been death that's true
go there your body anthem why not you
got to remember how much damage she's
putting on still this far in yeah
there's a break attached to put it back
into ready they go to catch him in old I
could this gospel rockin up but no drop
it oh there it is you got the wall he
keeps his head like he wouldn't even
need to be at the wall but that wall
combo was gonna insult anymore
I was faced a little bit they have a no
big deal no punches all the lethal hit
now the hair is wet down walk on the low
right there it's gonna be able to into a
piece four sticks of butter what are
they gonna do yeah hasn't been used as
much as some other matches but if you
only because it's been of a different
situation there it is from Lolo trying
to use that's a game to advancing right
back into his favorite right
oh wow just purely off axis the sole
charge to get his advantage right back
Oh is he gonna wall here too or no he
just looks or the bad damage oh my
goodness mystery finishing take a
sidewalk there but it's all good Lolo
burning soul charge to gain his
positioning advantage that's all that
should be a bonus right there oh god you
breathe a no no not a comment okay what
last piece of should you at one final
hit hello the biggest block right there
and then he catches them right and what
so one right now I have a feeling this
is going down to the wire and that's the
way we like it around here's my guys go
bringing it back giving it to the people
of the real question is below low stay
on the Mina or will he switch it up his
Mina's putting in work is made of doing
absolutely incredible stone I don't know
if you would want to switch it I think
that it looks like there was those tapes
like really good because I think his
Mina is actually doing quite incredible
in this matchup so keeping with that
would be a pretty slick his Mina has
also just been doing incredible in
general right it's not even just this
matchup
I'll keep earlier his meaning very
clearly looks to form okay oh my god
Jesus so much guard game gym guard do
sandwich in only goodness make it stop
it's already starting to flash soon no
miss GI right there no real big punish
on it but you still got some damage but
there is the launcher punch right there
got the just frame it yeah you text back
so your text into the leaflet yeah boys
boys got his cheeks out he's ready to go
that's right extra agile hey time to
catch them stepping and you can finally
got exactly that it's gonna be able to
get a little bit extra damage there's
let's blow all good news right Aleppo
hit him
it's a guard breaks already guard
breaking round why that's dress that's
like crazy me to know yeah the pressure
is serious but I mean he's currently
pushing at the ledge right there there
was the dodging okay but there's the
sole charge that slow down the clock
he's barely got that much help out of
here and there it is he just got BB
while he was running forward he did it
preemptively and Lola McSwain his face
into it
here we go still has one meter to work
with you two
what will he do this Isis oh [ __ ] the
load there and block again they're the
perfect punish trying to slide in the DN
but not two days as Mina I don't want
you size around me oh wow you think the
stance to be able to get around that
situation didn't want any extra card
damage right you have been talking about
how the pressure was so much that the
car damage just became such a factor he
found a way around it away from that
wall putting her towards it doesn't
matter Lolo won't let this man play the
game or mix-up he blocks it gets them
all right think and there it is the
sweep again getting around a piece right
now here in the winners finals eyes I
said it might go down to the wire and
boys looking like it blocking that low
though another break attack forcing the
sole charge right now has no mercy
all right never go big boy launches Oh
Cathy expense of a lot of soul gates but
I mean took over half of his life right
no punish on it all right Big Chill and
be careful of the bring up attention for
me no always I'm friends with soldier
the flashing red guard scary business oh
there we go punish right there he's
gonna be able to get mixed up after this
watch them in and now he's gonna put
pressure right here on skill sure he's
all know that's a big one that could
have been punished Oh random and neat
shining wizard expose kneecaps rig let's
go for a samurai here we go Lomo kicking
him I'm taking it down low shoot the
floor what you got coming up next oh oh
wow what spacing Rikers you just was
able to step back outside of the break
inside and then immediately step back in
getting the full punish has really great
positioning right now has effects
whistle oh my god God that the guard
broken for his troubles unfortunately go
and then up another guard break up oh
man that skill definitely came out on
top on that one and he's also gonna get
this game because of it I think
speaking of all top bang just like that
having to one so far don't forget get
through the first two three scenario
though still needs one more to rock it
out taking deep breath he's feeling he's
peeling it in his soul
when you took that sidestep and just be
time to end you III give it a not
pinpoint whether or not low load did a
missed into it or there just was nothing
that he could do after that heartbreak
possibly because you know there's
certain guard breakers that we - formal
characters to call break with that could
have been one of them I'm not sure but
whatever the case may be he didn't get a
lot of damage afterwards
it may have come back to on him but he
got a lot of damage for this possibly no
drops it try to get the bathroom right
there but no dice right as Lola was like
a pretty fine it blocks the low on that
time not getting lethal hit on this and
again he's been ducking under a lot of
Lola's options but oh there you go lola
doing strange things taking round one
now you say he's trying to play so solid
just looking him in the eyes i mean
that's what's killed himself at its own
place penalty that's exactly what he
wants to do he doesn't want to take big
farm like you didn't want to have heart
read too much written so this entire
batch actually yeah you're totally right
about that actually that might have
actually been of this match put in
particular online i'm not sure about the
other matches in this set so far but day
well that one gets broken on the front
escape a lot of damage here for skill he
is looking pretty on this round
okay the connor hit that might give them
a chance to finish it off
he's trying to get a little bit of extra
damage on the line oh wow just outside
of the range of it that is the second
time he has steps just closed step out
and then step back into punished after a
whip but that's about to bleed here we
go back on the damage for days is he
bought the sole charge no he's just to
go for the oh no here this time yeah
great call here we go that's gonna
punish it right there skill currently
offset point here doing it for his fin
know in just like that is the exact same
situation same thing just roll around
town putter sit for his since got two
bars over low low you can set something
up here pretty soon
Oh lethal again oh he's got him low
trying to back off right there and I
mean I'd skills movement has been so
excellent I feel like it's been pretty
hard to get something started
he's up close kind of happened but oh
caught him in out of the sea II got the
hit this one C will connect however
there we go
lo-lo's fighting to stay alive in the
winter side but skill only needs one
more round to advance into grand finals
right now I feel like he's gonna do it
it's gonna be look at how big the life
lead is right now and he's gonna have to
deal with a 50/50 afterwards at the
legend he backs off cause he doesn't
want to deal with like he's like the one
thing I can lose is is a reverse ring
out right so let's let's not chance it
let's just get damage here and there and
skill it moves on to the winners side of
grand finals
constantly constantly using that Ruby to
the best of his ability and always
keeping the the smart game in mind right
he goes why play risky but I can just
make you play my game make you respect
me make you play my game incredible
incredible job Lolo was still in the
tournament though he will be running it
through looser side now I'm sitting
pretty and losers finals but next up we
actually will have is link boys versus
bleep